this is complex ooh the alemão it's one
of rio's most dangerous favelas it's a
side of the city the rest of the world
rarely sees a cable car is the only link
between this impoverished neighborhood
and the rich areas on the waterfront but
it stopped running another shooting
nearby means authorities have closed it
down cutting off the favela people's
lives are disrupted by the war between
drug dealers and police to mention a
physical problem it's become harder to
live here because of all the shootings
they happen every day kids just don't
come home from school it's difficult
because the cable car often doesn't run
many residents of the favelas support
the PT Workers Party but not necessarily
Dilma Rousseff they remain loyal to her
predecessor lula da silva and say under
his presidency their lives actually
improved I drew up a geminal Dilma has
no influence here but Lula was a good
president this behind us this was thanks
to him but when there are shootings all
the nice stuff makes no difference I
guess we can't go anywhere when the
headshot much what about you know
there's you know why do you need me ask
people on the Copacabana if they know
what's going on here they wouldn't know
damn on the Copacabana what's the main
concern and isopropyl person my biggest
worry and I think that it's something
that worries all of Brazil is the
current economic situation we need a
good government here in Brazil after 13
years of the PT being in charge were in
a bad situation in the middle of a
recession corruption and it just goes on
and on what I went to damn
in her own party Dilma Rousseff is
losing support her job is being done by
Michel temer while her fate on
corruption charges is decided yet it's
in the favelas that she still has
staunch supporters you'll get to see
your might say get rid of tammer were
the poor and we don't accept the current
government it's not legitimate Dilma was
voted in by over 50 million people I
voted for because her policies benefit
the people here in the poorer areas must
benefit is the Brazilian Senate is due
to vote this week on whether to formally
remove her from office if they do Dilma
Rousseff would be the first Brazilian
President to lose the job through
impeachment